fucking maintower interesse sowohl diese
plattform ist geisteskrank ich bin so
heiß darauf was in den nächsten tagen
noch passieren werde
das ist mir so unfassbar unangenehm in
den letzten jahren gab es eine plattform
die sich dieses explosionsartiges
wachstum mit an die spitze aller social
media plattform gesetzt hat aber was
genau auf diese plattform aus und wie
schwer ist es auch tik tok erfolgreich
zu werden
tik tok oder damals noch durch hindu ist
eine aus china stammende erst 2016 von
weiter ins gegründete plattform die
mittlerweile über 75 milliarden dollar
marktwert hat und damit das
erfolgreichste start ups anfang 2018
verschmolzen haben wir hin und musicali
zudem trug was wir heute kennen die
plattform ist auf kurze unterhaltungs
videos ausgelegt welche weit über
normale lip sync videos hinausgehen und
damit quasi so ein bisschen der
nachfolger von baier die er tatsächlich
ist ja nun einmal rot und weiß deshalb
gar nicht so richtig was sie eigentlich
ausmacht was ich aber weiß ist dass auch
die unfassbare und leider sahen erreicht
werden können also mit umfasst waren
meine ich wirklich umfasst mal weil das
stellt alles in den schatten was man
vorher von insta und youtube und so
gewohnt ist dieser effekt und das wissen
dass häufig relativ einfach umzusetzende
konzepte die einschlaegigsten sind und
am besten funktionieren lässt einen
denken das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht
so schwer sei auf tik tok erfolgreich zu
haben
wie schwer es ist wirklich wie schwer
ist es als jemand erfolgreich zu werden
der keine online präsenz nicht besonders
stark auf social media ist viel spaß mit
lief es in drei tagen optik erfolgreich
zu werden so wundert euch nicht was
jetzt passiert ich probiere natürlich in
meiner position in drei tagen möglichst
erfolgreich auf tik tok zu werden
deswegen benutze ich auch alle meine
möglichkeiten ich habe deswegen dachte
ich mir vielleicht mache ich mal etwas
besonderes und von meiner person dazu
könnte
sein eindruck holzmaden das ist mein
gast für heute das ist wir machen jetzt
ein paar tik tok videotapes blatter soll
was mir jetzt einfach bananen der raum
lebens angeschwollen die bananen ja cool
hört man also es schneit es endlich mit
run ist es wirklich nicht
also ja ich habe die relativ trocken und
zwar so auch dabei genau meistens auch
dabei der cloud eben die kamera gemacht
und jetzt film wir erstmal wir haben so
zwei verschiedene konversationen einmal
revue vom green screen ich einmal auf
dem sofa und da müssen wir nachher alles
zusammen schneiden als allererstes
machen jetzt das auf 1 156 verschiedene
stück zu machen deswegen muss das
relativ fix gehen und ich gebe mehr auf
dem wasser als auf qualität das ist
übrigens die golden sandale der
einkreist ja einmal im jahr von ihren
wird übrigens im übrigen so beim zweiten
tag geht es darum dass ich mir einmal
revue dabei wünsche und er als normaler
ruhiger mensch kommt und beim zweiten
mal kommt er eben als richtiger revie
und zeigt wir für gewöhnlich so drauf
ist macht jetzt einmal die kamera und
ich stelle mein handy einfach hin und
dann brauche ich nicht mal mit nur um
dieses tik tok filmkamera alles selber
also ist wirklich krass auf tik tok das
habe ich jetzt schon gemerkt man habe so
viele möglichkeiten und man kann die
sachen häufig so schnell machen und
einfach jede dumme idee umsetzen das
macht richtig eine viel geringere
einstiegshöhe da ist bei youtube page
handys ist button ich bin superhappy hat
man einfach so ich glaube ja ripley
malta perfekt genau das ist das was wir
brauchen und du rufst du reviere und
brüllt du ihn so komplett zusammen mit
dem megafon also wir sind hier jetzt 20
minuten an drehen und haben schon zwei
sachen fertig gemacht und ich schätze in
den nächsten fünf minuten werden wir die
nächsten zwei fertig machen also es ist
wirklich super easy ja das habe ich
damals auch gedacht ich habe jetzt im
endeffekt doch so viel mehr energie in
das projekt gesteckt als ich eigentlich
gedacht hätte und das ist so anstrengend
weil sich das video gefällt lassen
irgendeine reaktion auf dieses video da
teilt das mit euren freunden damit
heftig mir beim start von diesem kanal
ungemein deswegen will ich mich selber
hilfe freuen
viel spaß mit dem video es passiert noch
verrücktes zeug außerdem fühle mich
gerade denselben tik tok zweimal und
balladen vor bei der auswahl ist völlig
klar wird innerhalb von einer stunde 10
15 ticks gemacht wie könnt ihr über den
link in der beschreibung alle sehen habe
ich nicht alle gefilmt was wir jetzt
aber machen es probieren eine neue
challenge zu introduce in diesen
challenge dingen werden sich diese
aufbaut auf tik tok ist megagroß ich
glaube nicht dass wir es schaffen werden
aber ein versuch ist es wert und wenn
dann am kopf kriegen wir nicht an die
durch zufall sondern komme schon trick
raus gefunden bei dem wir gegen seit
über die hand des anderen steigt kennst
du die leute anfangs so werden immer so
machen wir zeigen euch einmal wie die
challenge aus dem wir nennen sie die
stellen dann trifft sich
das ist genau so dass wir jetzt noch
einmal für tik tok und dann geht das
durch die berge so freunde ich habe
gerade das erste tik tok gelaunt genau
dieses hier das video ist online
gegangen die ersten fünf minuten so
nichts ist passiert haben sind sich hier
draußen zehn minuten später
ich habe 1200 views einfach so fünf
minuten wie sind sie darauf gekommen
die rund 200 die jungs so viel mache ich
auf ein youtube-video nach 24 stunden
wenn max das teilte diese plattform ist
geistes kann ich bin so hype darauf was
in den nächsten tagen noch passieren
wird ich halte euch up today warte jetzt
erst mal noch die anderen weiter hoch
aber kalt so tag zwei nach dem ersten
tag den ich gestern hochgeladen habe
dann wirklich 1300 - nach zehn minuten
oder so hatte habe ich die anderen
restlichen vier oder fünf hochgeladen
und seitdem nicht mehr reingekommen ich
bin mir aber ziemlich sicher dass
irgendwas passiert sein muss denn ich
habe einfach so 50 oder 60 neue
abonnenten auf instagram bekommen wenn
man sich überlegt dass 50 oder 60 leute
erstmal diesen schritt machen müssen auf
das tik tok profil auf insta und dann
noch zu abonnieren
da muss wohl irgendwas passiert sein
fast 100 k 94.000 aufrufe 12.500 likes
das ist ein tick tock in dem ich nicht
mal zu sehen bin in dem drei wie zu
sehen das war vielleicht ein bisschen
absehbar so ein video wurde gesperrt
rewe hatte zwei pistolen in der hand die
ziemlich echt aussahen max hat von
vornherein gesagt dass wir die noch ganz
nehmen sollen wir haben es nicht für
wichtig gehalten war vielleicht ein
bisschen absehbar dass das doch
irgendwie gegen die community
richtlinien verstößt aber naja ok ich
muss das hier noch mal ganz kurz auf den
punkt bringen falls ich das nicht ganz
deutlich gemacht habe gerade insgesamt
habe ich 841 follower über nacht
generiert habe 12.500 ley und das meist
geklickte video hat 95.000 aufruf 95.000
sie wird in den letzten zwei wochen zwei
videos hochgeladen die insgesamt
wahrscheinlich einen aufwand hatten der
10 20 mal so groß war oder 30 mal und
dieses video hat fünfmal soviel aufrufe
die insgesamt die komplette arbeit die
ich mir in den letzten zwei wochen mit
meinen youtube videos gemacht hat
gefragt hier noch mal ganz kurz tic toc
damit über weiß worüber ich spreche
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen uns aber auch ganz klar
vor augen halten warum war das zu
erstens ich war nicht mal in dem tic toc
nur max und sebastian dessen gesichter
im internet doch ganz okay bekannt sind
der rest formulierung er warum genau so
sieht die kommentar section auch aus
überall steht ist das revier ist das
revier ist das rwi ist es marxist des
reviers ismail keiner von beiden hat ein
tick tock account und dass die beiden
auf der plattform zu sehen sind ist
natürlich irgendwie was besonderen genau
diese interaktion ist im endeffekt der
ausschlaggebende punkt dafür dass dieses
video gebaut auf der anderen seite gibt
es auch sehr viele kommentare die auf
dieses hacker ding an sich eingegangen
sind und die glaube ich den tick tock an
sich auch ganz cool fanden aber so
erfolgreich wäre dieser tik tok nicht
gewesen wenn max und rewe nicht die
gesichter im video gewesen wären
deswegen darf ich mir das auf gar keinen
fall so jetzt auf meine fahne schreiben
[Musik]
ja völlig crazy übrigens ist mir noch
eine erklärung an gefallen warum diese
views und likes so immens auf tik tok
sind die videos denn so kurz manchmal
fünf zehn oder 15 sekunden lang das
einfach viel viel mehr videos konsumiert
werden können das bedeutet auf ein
youtube-video das zehn minuten lang ist
wovon fünf minuten geguckt wurden wurde
ein klick generiert das bedeutet bei
fünf minuten tik tok konsum und einer
durchschnittlichen länge von 15 sekunden
pro video hätte man 20 klicks generiert
das bedeutet 20 zu 1 das bedeutet nicht
dass man das einfach ins verhältnis
setzen kann aber es ist einfach
hervorzuheben dass auf tik tok in viel
kürzerer zeit viel mehr klicks generiert
werden aber egal wie ich da jetzt weiter
drum rumreden hunderttausend views auch
ein video oder beziehungsweise auf den
channel der bisher nichts gemacht hatte
fucking mind blowing also wirklich das
ist völlig
ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen dass ich
ziemlich motiviert bin jetzt die
nächsten zwei tage noch komplett durch
zu ballern unangenehm mir das auch ist
werde ich jetzt wohl auf tik tok
cleanskin store starten mit summen sie
makeover video wo man zuerst hässlich
ist und dann schön wird kann ich ja
alles was ich mache hinter diesem
projekt verstecken
immer schön rausreden dass ich das
natürlich sonst niemals machen so ich
habe jetzt gerade genau diesen tick tock
hier aufgenommen
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie groß
die hürde für mich ist das hochzuladen
das ist mir so unfassbar unangenehm ich
glaube das ist das was ich machen muss
damit es gepackt oder im zweiten sektor
habe ich auch der explore page gefunden
das zu einer der top trending hashtags
und das heißt in germany aber geht es
darum dass man auf englisch zuerst
einsatz sagt den dann auf deutsch
übersetzt und dann sagt dann gibt es
keine juden entschuldigen sie spreche
ich mit dem ordnungsamt einen
abschleppwagen bitte in die
richard-wagner-straße nachdenken als
keine hilfe kommt immer wieder zurück in
diese position um zu sagen was ich
gerade für ein tick tock gemacht habe
manchmal zum guten iphone 11 pro
deswegen kann er mir beim nächsten tik
tok aushelfen mega der trend gerade auf
tik tok dass so eine stimme kommen dann
sagt man zeigt man was das neue iphone
kann genau das machen wir uns zeigen die
kamerafunktion in dem max mich einmal im
weitwinkel einmal normal und einmal im
tele zoom filmt und das war's tipp 3
fertig dass bei diesen drei stopps jetzt
anders gemacht haben als bei den letzten
alle von gestern habe ich erst auf dem
rechner geschnitten dann rübergezogen
und bahnen hochgeladen alle die ich
heute mache neben instant tik tok auf
und lädt die sofort ich habe jetzt die
ersten 36 hochgeladen sind gerade in
düsseldorf wenn so verholt
so viel sagen es geht weiter es geht
auch ohne revier und max wieder in
klickzahlen in kurzer zeit die unfassbar
sind also world toques ich werde die
nicht zeigen dafür müsst ihr das zweite
video einschalten das ab samstag kommt
alles was jetzt noch an tag 2 und 3
passiert müsst ihr dann am samstag im
video schauen ich hoffe er beim zu sehen
genauso viel spaß wie beim produzieren
im endeffekt war es jetzt so anstrengend
und ich habe so viel energie
reingesteckt dass ich wirklich hoffe
dass man das merkt und das ist brauch
ich ankommen mit ihr das video am
samstag und alle die noch kommen nicht
verpasst vergesst nicht zu abonnieren
wir sehen uns dann cherry